Movie-watching can be an enriching communal
experience, but some films are better enjoyed
solo.
Contemplative dramedies, slow-burning thrillers,
dialogue-free dramas — certain films are
best absorbed all by yourself, with zero distractions.
For example ...
All Is Lost
Robert Redford's ability to grip audiences
with a compelling performance has never waned
throughout his long career.
That gift is particularly evident in J.C.
Chandor's All Is Lost, an acclaimed 2013 drama
in which Redford's unnamed sailor endures
a litany of increasingly life-threatening
mishaps during a solo ocean voyage.
Watching this film alone is a transformative
experience.
There's only one character and he hardly ever
speaks, which makes sounds that ordinarily
might not be noticed all the more intriguing.
With most of the sound coming from the main
character shuffling around, what would normally
be an ordinary background detail becomes a
key factor in the film's immersion.
Every detail in All Is Lost requires your
full attention.
Gravity
Alfonso Cuarón's hit 2013 space drama Gravity
is a film that filled theaters for weeks—but
in order to truly exert its devastating impact,
it needs to be seen alone.
For one, the filmmakers do an excellent job
of projecting panic onto the audience after
Sandra Bullock's character is marooned in
space.
Fear is alleviated somewhat in a group setting,
so truly putting yourself in her position
requires watching the film alone.
Whether or not there's sound in space is up
for debate, but Cuarón's command of Gravity's
soundtrack is the second reason you should
watch it by yourself—and with the volume
high.
It's the type of film in which the intensity
continuously builds, amplified by the skillful
use of sound.
Even the crescendo in the score allows audiences
to feel the emotional weight of Bullock's
character's struggle to reach Earth—and
survive.
It's a thrillride best experienced alone,
with nothing to distract you.
Into the Wild
Based on the novel of the same name by Jon
Krakauer, Into the Wild tells the true story
of Christopher McCandless, a recent college
grad who braved the Alaskan wilderness in
the early '90s and sadly passed away a few
months into his trek.
Into the Wild's judgment-free dramatization
of McCandless' doomed pilgrimage offers a
perfectly introspective example of a movie
that makes the view think about what they
would do in a similar situation.
Who knows, maybe you'll be inspired to abandon
materialism and go on a solo adventure of
your own in the Alaskan wilderness.
It's an incredibly dangerous proposition,
but you wouldn't be the first.
The Fountain
Darren Aronofsky's filmography is studded
with Biblical symbolism, and The Fountain,
starring Hugh Jackman and Rachel Weisz as
star-crossed lovers, offers a particularly
absorbing example.
The film is a visual spectacle, to say the
least, but its three storylines are just as
finely crafted—and easy to lose track of
if you aren't paying close attention.
Lose concentration and you could easily miss
details crucial to grasping the story as a
whole.
The Fountain is an exceptionally emotional
story, but watching it unfold with a group
of friends might very well take you out of
the moment.
The Assassination of Jesse James by the Coward
Robert Ford
It may be slow at times—okay, most of the
time—but this dramatization of the titular
infamous killing never stops building in intensity,
due in large part to the stylized directing
style of Andrew Dominik and the masterful
eye of cinematographer Roger Deakins.
The train robbery scene, in particular, is
an excellent example of just how hypnotic
cinematography can be.
Do yourself a favor and tune out chatter during
a masterpiece like The Assassination of Jesse
James by the Coward Robert Ford.
Lost in Translation
Featuring one of Bill Murray's greatest performances,
along with exceptional work from Scarlett
Johansson, Lost in Translation earned Sofia
Coppola the third Best Director nomination
offered to a woman in Oscars history.
It isn't that taking in Lost in Translation
with a crowd will make you lose sight of the
story—there isn't much of a plot—but the
self-reflection the movie motivates stands
to be lost in a group.
Like Johansson's character learns in that
unforgettable final scene, there are some
secrets you only learn when you're leaning
in close enough to hear a whisper.
Any of Hayao Miyazaki's films
Legendary Japanese filmmaker Hayao Miyazaki
has done more for animation than many casual
filmgoers might realize.
His movies may not be as well-known to the
general public as Disney's library of hits,
but from The Castle of Cagliostro to The Wind
Rises, Miyazaki and his Studio Ghibli have
expanded the animation genre to make room
for sophisticated storytelling and exceptionally
beautiful visuals.
They aren't event movies, though, and they
aren't made for watching with a group of friends.
Tackling thought-provoking themes in their
own distinctive style, Miyazaki movies demand
the type of emotional room you can only get
solo.
No Country for Old Men
Based on the Cormac McCarthy novel of the
same name, this modern Western thriller won
Best Picture and Best Director at the Oscars.
It's considered one of the greatest films
of the century, as well as the Coen brothers'
masterpiece…and that's saying something.
If you're unfamiliar with the form, Westerns
can be slow, punctuated with intermittent
bursts of heightened action, and No Country
for Old Men is a prime example.
The tension, suspense, and thrills never stop
building, yet the film as a whole is eerily
quiet.
If you're forced to deal with distractions
during the movie, you'll be taken right out
of the story—breaking its spell and ruining
the experience altogether.
"Yes sir.
I got it under control."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!